hey everyone Spencer here and today
we're looking at watchdogs 2 DLC human
condition we're going to be taking a
look at the yacht mission on this one
what was one of the favorite things you
loved to hack in this game leave a
comment down below and if you enjoyed
this video feel free to like share and
subscribe for more damn I want to change
the terms of our relationship knowing
full well that you have little reason to
trust me I got zero reason to trust you
man you crazy as hell you know what
that's fair
that is that is fair but see the thing
is I don't have any real reason to kill
you anymore because I don't gain from it
so you can go ahead and put away your
little ball gag there [ __ ] no Stice huh
crawling with Bratva but the thing is is
you're gonna need me to thin out that
hurt a little bit so you can get in
there and shut down that spyware
ransomware man whatever here's how I
figure I clip Anton shut down the
operation so win-win your people are
happy my groups happy everybody's happy
well except for Anton of course cuz he's
dead
ya know still don't trust you it's good
instinct
hold on to that instinct huh I'm gonna
go anyway uh finished my mint chocolate
chip it's great
I hate mint chocolate chip that's why
champion drama hula
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah market broken
[Music]
Hey damn
oh yeah
the hell man that's all of them Josh
it was Anton knows his security I'm
seeing two more backup relays just lit
up well plans within plans
hopefully not plans within plans within
plants your fingers crossed
I was going to [ __ ] this up
you got them all Marcus the ransomware
key should be locked in place now
perfect
I'll go hack back into Anton's computer
and get the [ __ ] out of here
all right fingers crossed
okay it's downloaded
[Music]
of course there he is
[Applause]
you